sofia vergara put to rest any rumors  she's hiding a baby bump when she  stepped out in this hot pink number the  spelt modern family star attended a  special screening of the hit show where  each he got an update on her husband Joe  Manganiello after he was reportedly  hospitalized with serious appendicitis  everyone has been asking us for getting  the comments about how Joe is how is he  can you give us an update on him yeah  he's great he's doing great yeah his  health is ok yeah he's okay he had a  little you know told him but nothing  okay he tweeted a couple weeks ago he  said I love my wife and our audience  went nuts over it what was behind that  tweet why did he say that um I don't  know I'm always very special with him so  he must have been one of my normal days  how I am